e quando eu tinha 12 anos eu vi um vídeo
de animais sendo abatidos e isso foi
bastante traumatizante para mim então
Desde aquela época eu comecei a repensar
todas as questões acerca do consumo de
produtos de origem animal na minha vida
e aí foram várias tentativas até que
quando eu completei 17 anos eu parei do
dia para noite com todo o consumo de
carne peixe e Franco e naquele tempo as
únicas referências que eu tinha era
pessoas que criavam vídeos criavam
conteúdo para o Youtube pão aumento bem
complicado porque muitas dessas
referências eram pessoas que usavam
produtos inacessíveis e industrializados
fazem o receitas difíceis que eu não
consegui
os ingredientes fácil e até comiam
frutas que eram muito difíceis de achar
aqui na minha cidade teve uma vez que eu
fui com meu pai andar por toda a cidade
para tentar achar blueberry e framboesas
só que a gente não conseguiu encontrar
porque era bem difícil achar essas
frutas aqui E além disso quando a gente
achou era muito caro e eu base Ei meu
vegetarianismo nisso em frutas que eu
nem sabia o nome e em produtos
industrializados e por isso foi bem
complicado e consequentemente se tornou
bem caro ser vegetariana naquela época
mas aí eu tomei coragem e depois de um
ano e quatro meses eu decidi me tornar
vegana e retirar todos os produtos de
origem animal do meu prato eu
e aprendido muito desde aquela época do
blubell e para é por causa da
transmissão então eu costumo dizer que
foi uma transição alimentar e também uma
transmissão de ideias e de pensamentos
porque foi naquela época que eu aderi
uma alimentação crudívora só comendo
basicamente frutas e vegetais e nada que
ano fogo então foi aí que eu comecei a
pensar EA repensar na acessibilidade dos
produtos de origem vegetal e entrar em
contato com agricultura familiar e
camponesa com feras alimentos orgânicos
E além disso com pequenos produtores
também foi aí que eu percebi o quão era
barato alimentação à base de vegetais EA
diversidade do reino vegetal que é muito
mais além dos produtos industrializados
uma das coisas
eu dou foi procurar inspiração em
pessoas que tinham a mesma realidade ou
realidade próxima já minha pessoas que
dissemina vão pegar nismo popular e
organismo acessível foi sobre aprender
que com a cenoura e uma batata eu posso
fazer cheddar catupiry e queijos veganos
e molho para macarrão fazer refogados e
ainda aproveitar todas as cascas que eu
geralmente jogava fora e fazer petiscos
bem gostosos então eu entrei no
verganista achando que a luta era apenas
sobre libertação animal mas ao longo do
caminho Eu reconheci que as faltas de
organismo acabam transpassando muitos
outros temas é uma luta transversal que
se conecta e que cria relações com
outras lutas como por exemplo feminismo
e o
bom então vai ser uma luta também por
soberania alimentar vai ser uma luta por
mais comida sem veneno na mesa dos
trabalhadores por acesso a comida
saudável para todos pelos recursos
naturais e pelos animais humanos e não
humanos que habitam nosso planeta e foi
aí que eu decidi que é um Instagram o
Instagram chamado Eco fada para mostrar
como é barato comer alimentação vegetal
e também desmistificar certos
preconceitos acerca do veganismo mostrar
que apesar de ser um movimento que é
visto como branco e elitizado existe eu
mulher negra e nordestina falando sobre
diabetes alimentares e mostrando como
alimentação à base de vegetais pode ser
acessível e que necessita se
popularizada é por isso que eu digo que
nós vaga
Nós não precisamos que nos veem Voice
nós precisamos mesmo é de espaços eu
criei e eu comprei o meu espaço com eco
fada e lá eu tento passar e mostrar
todos os dias que comer é um ato
político e revolucionário obrigada a